among other things
in my academic and scholarly career i am
a saint anselm scholar that is i am
somebody who
focuses on the works the thought the
life the importance the influence
of saint anselm of canterbury also known
as saint anselm went back saint anselm
iosta depending on on where you are
because
the english like to claim him as their
own with canterbury the french like to
claim him as
as their own through back and the
italians like to claim him as
their own through host at three places
that he spent portions of his life
um this is you know this this
development of becoming a saint anselm
scholar which has been going on for me
for over a decade is not something i
would have
ever have predicted or
let alone expected
when i was early on in my philosophical
career
you know i didn't really have much much
use for for christian thinkers to begin
with
when i was an undergraduate other than
kierkegaard
and that was because of his emphasis on
individuality
and even you know a good ways into my
graduate career
if you would have told me that
you know midway through my life at the
40-year point i would be working on a
book
on on saint anselm and actually more
than one book but you know
got to get one done before you start
talking about the others
um i would have probably laughed at you
and said well
who do you think you're fooling so i
think the story
about how i became a saint anselm
scholar and and why i'm so interested in
this guy
what i find so so fruitful um
it's an interesting story it's a very
idiosyncratic
story too it's got its twists and turns
that again would have been very
difficult to predict
and probably would not have have worked
as a path for many other people but did
for me because of my own predilections
and uh my own
weird areas of interest and my own
quirks
and my own narrative and history and i i
have to say i'm very pleased
um about how things have gone along the
way
and i also have to say that
um i have to be very grateful to to many
people for encouraging my
my interest in anselm and for giving me
the right nudges and the right pushes at
the right times
um so sometimes i took advantage of them
sometimes they didn't
and i i like to think that saint anselm
himself
has a role in that not merely as
a thinker but as as part of a
a larger community as part of a
communion
so what i'm going to talk about in this
this video is a little bit more
structured than some of the other
philosophical development videos i am
going to talk about
um anselm's writings
and you know what this guy actually did
and who he was
a little bit i'm going to talk about my
own timeline which i
i managed to plot out of uh how i became
an anselm scholar what were the the key
things
um i'm going to talk about a particular
place
and i've got some some not video footage
but some pictures i'm going to show you
and
talk a little bit over it a place that's
been particularly important for me as an
ansem scholar and i think
is a an important place in general for
anselm scholarship
and a place that i very much would love
to see uh
grow and become yet more fruitful and
become a locust for
for anselm scholarship and
for for younger scholars coming up in
the in the ranks to get their
their their push and their pull the way
i did from
from it and that is the institute for
saint anselm studies at saint anselm's
college
in manchester new hampshire and i'll
talk about about that in a few minutes
and then i'll talk about what um what
anselm means to me
in in particular as a
not just a scholar but a person
so saint anselm has left us quite a body
of work and writings
and it's interesting stuff most of it
has been translated a lot of it's been
translated
many times by by multiple people
um as a matter of fact there's a new
translation apparently the pro slogan
coming out with with commentary
uh through saint augustine's press
that's probably been his most
translated work i would say um
and i'd like to talk a little bit about
just to give you an impression about
what this guy did uh and the framework
in which he did it
about his his writings and and sort of
situate that in
in the framework of his his his life as
a whole
and you know you can say i think if
there's
one thing to say about anselm as a a
thinker a scholar a writer
it's that he got his writing done
despite being pulled off
in multiple directions by
many people at different points in his
life
yeah that's that's probably the best way
to put it because he's a guy
who was you know very very competent and
also very saintly
um sometimes these clashed admirer tells
us a little bit about that in one of his
his uh stories in the life of saint
anselm which by the way is a great work
to read if you want to know something
about this guy
and some it it may come across as kind
of hey geographical you know that is you
know kind of hazy aura of sainthood
about the guy
but really um there's a lot of prosaic
incidents in there which which are
probably pretty accurate in representing
who this guy was we look at the other
evidences that we have and we know that
anselm himself
looked over the stuff anselm had a
scrupulous regard for her truth
um and uh
didn't say that anything and it was was
particularly untruthful
so um
anyway anselm was a guy who
early on decided that he had some sort
of religious vocation but wasn't quite
sure what it was
and he came from a noble family in iosta
um which was in burgundy at that time
now it's part of italy
and he fled across the alps there's a
whole interesting story there
went into france at that time was you
know split up into a whole bunch of
different little kingdoms and and
normandy was an important part of it
and the normans had recently conquered
england
um anselm is is is a contemporary of all
these great
great events that are taking place in
the uh
the 11th century um
so anselm eventually settles down at
back becomes a monk
and then gets promoted to pryor which is
the sort of second in command in a
monastery
who handles a lot of the day-to-day
business and also handled the education
uh of the monks and uh perhaps of other
other people there
at the monastery back um it was a new
monastery
and the abbot heroine was not a sort of
guy who'd come up through the ranks of
of uh you know the organization so to
speak he was an old warrior who settled
down and became a monk and then
eventually became an abbot
um when heroin died
anselm was elected uh really against his
his wishes to be abbot and he tried to
wiggle his way out of
it and he had to be told no you've been
chosen
you're the guy for the job and so he
took it on and he was a very good abbot
and he ran things very well
and that got him known over in
england where the you know the normans
were consolidating their conquest
and because the the norman um uh
monastery
back had some some little holdings here
and there where anselm would have to go
out and see
how are the monks doing over here and um
that brought him to the notice of the
king william rufus who decided
um i'm going to make him archbishop and
there's a whole long story there that
i'm not going to go into maybe i'll do a
video on that some other time
any case anselm was dragged
literally kicking and screaming and
installed his bishop
trying to get out of that couldn't do it
and
finally agreed to it and then not long
after that relations with the king
started to break down and
anselm was at the very heart of
very tangled church-state relations not
only in
england but all across europe the
gregorian reforms were in place there
were a lot of
there are a lot of problems within the
church as there always are at any given
point in time
anybody who thinks that this is an aside
but anybody who thinks that you know
there's a big scandal in the church or
something like that really they ought to
study some church history
and that'll put things into perspective
and you know it's not to take away from
the largeness of any one given scandal
but you'll realize that that's always
what's going on and it's not because you
know
it's such a bad institution or something
like that it's because it's
made up of human beings who are always
three-quarters screwed up and like you
know one quarter trying to do good
um anyway anselm was was at the heart of
that
and so he managed to get a lot of
writing done
during this time and some of his writing
is motivated by what he what he's going
through but a lot of it is motivated by
his his quest um
and we know this in part from some of
his his letters and and correspondence
with people
and we know this in part because some of
his prayers and meditations and and
because of
the life of saint anselm what his actual
um motivations were
why did he write in some cases he wrote
because the monks bugged him until he
would write down some of the things that
he was teaching orally
and sometimes he wrote because he wanted
to communicate the pleasure that the
thoughts that he had worked out
and that he was meditating upon had uh
communicated to him sometimes he he
wrote in order to provide
pieces for meditation practical
meditation
to help people get their lives straight
that's what a lot of his prayers and
meditations are actually intended to be
sometimes he wrote because he saw an
abuse that needed to be
corrected he saw a situation that you
know was going to get out of hand that
needed to be addressed
sometimes he wrote because there was a
theological problem that was actually
put before the the church his
his uh writings on the incarnation of
the of the word
for example are trying to combat some of
the
the
the problematic interpretations uh
coming out of dialectic uh that that
people were having of the trinity
or his his letter on the procession of
the holy spirit comes from the council
of bari where
anselm was one of the chief speakers on
the part of the the
the western church and its understanding
of things as opposed to the
the eastern the orthodox church probably
one reason why orthodox
quite often have a very dim view of
anselm by the way
anyway what did what did he write so
i've given you this long prologue what
did the guy write
well you can divide up his his corpus
into a number of different genres
of writing there's what we call the
treatises
and these are kind of a mixed bag
they include the monologian the
pro-slogan
the uh on truth on freedom of
of choice on the fall of the devil
why god became man on the virgin
conception
on the incarnation of the word on the
concordance
there's a whole long title to that that
i'm gonna sort of skip over
a lot of times people will put the on
the processional holy spirit in there
as well um and there's also the
on the on the grammarian which sometimes
gets gets you know
left out or ignored or downplayed and
then those are the ones that have been
translated there's also
the day simultaneous or on similitudes
which is attributed to anselm
and this is something kind of kind of
interesting to think about
there are a lot of works that are
actually
attributed to anselm in means patrologia
latina that's the sort of big compendium
of all the latin works of the
church doctors and fathers and people
like that
and um
the anselm got so famous that people
would write stuff and then attribute it
to him
even though he didn't write it because
that way they could get other people to
read it
now the day simultaneous what the the
scholars
you know scholars weigh up at the high
level um
i think like southern and people like
that
was that it it contained portions which
were perhaps not ensembian but the core
of it was actually on selman
and so southern reconstructed what he
calls the dehumanized which is not
translated yet i'm working on a
translation of it
uh and it's included in this memorials
of saint anselm along with some other
really really cool
works like uh the dicta anselmi
uh the literally the sayings of saint
anselm
which are recorded by uh one of his
fellow monks alexander
from from canterbury and they're cons
they're consistent with and they expand
upon and some of their teachings so
there's all this whole body of treatises
and some of these are sort of in a
meditative argumentative form
some of them are in dialogue form some
of them
are are more straightforward treatises
um
so they've got varied um what you call
genres to them
ansem also wrote
several meditations that we think three
um
and a number of prayers uh addressed to
um different different uh you know some
of them are addressed
to christ or um you know to
to god on behalf of one's friends to get
on behalf of one's enemies
um three of them are addressed to to
mary
and then there's a bunch of them that
are addressed to
figures that are particularly important
in the gospel story
like saint john the baptist
john the evangelist
mary magdalene peter um
then there's uh there's one to saint
benedict
and there's also one
to um
say nicholas and
these are really interesting
bits of work i shouldn't say bits i mean
they are
carefully constructed
edifices with you could think of them as
sort of
verbal constructions
that you don't sort of mumble along
wrote you know
and recite them
they're supposed to place you in this
dramatic
context in relation to the saint who is
an intercessor
with with god and they're supposed to
help you know something about yourself
they're they're they're instruments of
self knowledge
of awakening the right sort of
emotions and affections and
understanding
your your uh your past your present your
future
brilliant stuff so he wrote a lot of
those prayers and his prayers were very
popular they were circulated around a
lot of people used them as aids
to pray and also to meditate
he wrote a number of letters um hundreds
of them
and he actually had his letters saved
because he realized that these would be
useful for other people to to think
about it to
to to read later on down the line
um he didn't write a memoir or anything
like that but you know this is almost
sort of like
saving saving stuff for your memoirs
later on
and his letters reveal to us all
different sides of his his character
sometimes he's the practical
bishop who has to you know keep keep the
realm from falling apart you know
because it's always like one step away
from that
and enforce you know church discipline
on these these totally unruly
monks abbotts priests you know priests
that weren't where he said
says stuff like don't let that guy go
into town because
you know when he does he gets drunk and
then he causes all sorts of problems
um you know um he
wrote to a lot of noble people he had
family who he wrote to he had fellow
monks
he developed these friendships that are
carried out and we know about them
largely through epistolary relationships
um so anyway there's that whole corpus
of letters
there is the life of saint anselm by
ayad mer
which i would say is is great to
supplement by the
you know again the dicta on sell me the
sayings of saint anselm
um i think that pretty much covers it as
far as
the whole gamut of stuff and and you
know it takes a while to read your way
through this and it's stuff that you
need to read through
multiple times i'm still rereading
treatises that i've been reading for you
know
some of them more than 10 years and
getting more and more out of them each
time that i do
and that fits in very well with anselm's
conception of
writing and thinking and what it is that
human beings do
with um with language with with
reality that we're trying to grasp
so that gives you an overview of
anselm's works and kind of places them
in the context of his time and his
projects and his
his life he didn't get to write
everything that he wanted to
towards the end of his life he actually
um he actually said to some of his
fellow monks
i i meant to write this treatise on the
origin of the soul
and i didn't get to it and i don't think
anybody else is going to be able to get
to it now that i'm going to be gone
so that's kind of a fitting place to end
at this point in my career and this has
been going on for quite a while
a good portion of my scholarship is is
concerned with saint anselm's thought
and with digging into it
and trying to you know systematically
study it communicate it to other people
show how how saint anselm has something
to say about a lot of the things that
we're interested in
and and that's been going on for for
quite some time
for me if you take my my teaching out of
the picture
and my my other
work oriented in the same sort of things
my videos
all that out of the picture a lot of my
conference presentations my academic
writing
my my projects are oriented around uh
saint anselm
and how did that come to be well that's
kind of a long and tangled story
and i actually ended up having to sit
down and kind of plot it out and figure
out well how did i get from here to here
to here to here
because there's a number of different
projects that that culminated in in
articles or conference papers or things
like that along the way
so it really starts back in 1998 so
we're talking about 15 years ago
and in 1998 i had uh finished my masters
i wrote my master's thesis in in
continental philosophy
on ghost rule and i was particularly
interested in language
after abandoning a first abortive
attempt to write on wittgenstein in
language
which i've talked about in my my
victonian phase video
and i started reading anselm
um in part because i'd gotten tired of
reading
thomas aquinas stylistically not not
in terms of um his thought
or the content of it but i wanted i i
was working on my latin
and when you're working on latin one
thing that you have to do
is uh well any language you have to you
know read works in that language and
accumulate vocabulary and sort of like
practicing
and going on to an obstacle course so i
decided um look i'm gonna have to read
this guy
for i'd read him before anyway but i
never really paid much attention to him
i'm gonna have to read him for
my my preliminary examinations let's dig
into him
and by then i was kind of primed because
thomas aquinas
the experience of reading him in the
latin
uh and just reading around not just
reading what was prescribed for this
class or this class or this class
had shown me that my instructors their
take on thomas aquinas and his
philosophy was dead wrong
that there was a lot more there than i
had thought
that this this christian thinker uh who
really centered his metaphysics and his
moral theory
around god but incorporated a lot of
philosophy
had a lot of interesting things to say
um could could anticipate a lot of the
criticisms that would be made later on
so studying thomas had kind of primed me
for being able to take anselm a bit more
seriously
and i started reading the proslogen
i got myself the charlesworth facing
page edition that had the latin on one
side and
charlesworth's sometimes faithful
sometimes not quite so faithful
translations on on the other along with
charlesworth's terrible terrible
commentary
which takes about half the book where he
devotes like uh almost
all of the the commentary to through the
three chapters that are considered the
ontological argument
oh you know the rest of it he heard that
hardly discusses at all
um but as i was reading it i
i did find it more stylistically um
complex and anselm is very fond of using
the chiastic structure as
a way of arguing
and it's quite quite interesting what's
going on in there and
once i started getting a feel for the
language i also started getting a feel
for
some of the concepts and the fact that
the way in which the concepts
had been translated or were being
discussed by other people were not often
that that faithful to anselm's own text
so that started me and then in 1999 i
had to start preparing for my
preliminary examinations
at southern illinois university you took
four preliminary examinations
each was three and a half hours you had
three and a half hours to write
an essay answers to four questions
selected out of a pool of twelve
and each exam was focused on a
particular
area in percent of areas in philosophy
and focused
on a particular reading list and the
reading lists were immense
we we had a pluralistic department which
meant that we had analytic
classical american and continental
philosophy and a few history of
philosophy people
and everybody tried to shove their stuff
into that reading list as much as
possible
and you could literally you could be
asked questions
on anything in that reading list so you
had to
a lot of people try to game you know the
system i actually read everything on the
reading lists
i not only read everything on the
reading list studied
just about everything on the reading
list and so
for the metaphysics and philosophy of
religion one anselm's proselyon was on
there because of course the ontological
argument is part of that
so i you know i as i was preparing
and i was going through i was studying
not only for that but also for the value
fields exam at the same time
and you know i was reading some of the
same stuff that would show up in the
epistemology philosophy of science one
later on
um and i was also reading hegel too
because that was my special thinker you
had to have a special thinker exam
so i was reading a lot of the people
who had addressed anselm's argument
not just anselm himself but i was
reading thomas aquinas
i was reading uh descartes and of course
cassendi you know
his his uh objections to to
descartes meditations i was reading
john locke i was reading emmanuel kant i
was reading hegel
um and gradually this
is interesting because there was a a
question that i answered
on the the the exam and it had to do
with um
the ontological argument and i traced
out
this uh this sort of history
of ontological arguments starting with
anselm
and looking at anselm and goniello and
ganila's rejection of it and then thomas
aquinas's semi-rejection
because i i it was interesting i i
learned from
thomas's uh commentary on the psalms
which i i was translating parts of and
proofreading other people's translations
of
that thomas didn't really think that
anselm was wrong he just thought that
nobody's going to grant
all the stuff that you need in order to
get the argument going but that anselm
is actually correct
strictly speaking um so we had three
different you know
possibilities and some you know
ontological argument works here it is
canelo no it doesn't work at all it's
it's you know terrible
thomas aquinas well yeah it works but
there's better proofs
and then when we went to modern
philosophy we saw something similar
descartes
cassendi john locke when we get to
uh you know 19th well 18th 19th century
philosophy
we've got um kant as ganilo and
hegel sort of taking anselm's position
um so i included all of that in that
question
and that would show up later on in the
very first paper that i wrote
for for a conference so that takes us up
to 2000
and in 2000
fortunately for me providentially anselm
would say
there was a uh there was a
flyer on the bulletin board that had to
do with conferences and events and
things like that
and it said saint anselm his legacy and
influence the first and
the first uh saint anselm conference at
the
institute for saint anselm studies saint
anselm college manchester new hampshire
and by then um
this is actually before 2000 it was it
was late 1999 when i saw that i thought
well i just answered a prelim question
about that i can write a paper about
that
so i sent in a proposal and
it was accepted and i was you know still
a graduate student at the time i'd been
to a few conferences but not too many
and in the meantime though
you know while i was getting ready for
this my my uh
last remaining parent died and i had to
handle the
the inheritance and all that and so by
the time that april rolled around i just
barely got
my paper written and i flew out there to
to uh to new hampshire and i was you
know staying there
and it was a wonderful conference um
there were people first of all there
there were people who were
um you know catholics there there were
some orthodox there there were some
anglicans there because they're very
interested in anselm there are some
evangelicals there of course there were
some people who have
no religious you know connections
whatsoever there and
you know i'm sure there was some atheist
there as well but they didn't they
didn't make any big play of it there
um and there were monks because this is
a monastery
and their the monks were staying with
their fellow monks
at the monastery and um
it was a very different world to me i i
didn't grow up around that that sort of
thing
even though i grew up you know sort of
nominally catholic as as a kid
and um you know i heard some excellent
papers i got some good feedback on my
paper and then i met
two people who would um really
influence my my career as an ansem
scholar uh
for for the the better and they were
both benedict and monks
i actually credit both of them in a
later piece that i wrote with
with my vocation one of them is father
john fortin
who is from that abbey saint anselm's
abbey
um his great love is actually he's a
medieval
philosophy expert but he also has a
great love for um
international relations he can talk all
day long about that sort of stuff
brilliant guy
um great organizer as well and he was
the first
um person in charge of the the saint
anselm institute
so i got to talking with him and he was
very down to earth and he was very
encouraging
and uh just a very
he's a guy who um he has somewhat of a
a gruff exterior at times but there's a
lot of love in him
and i got to see that on on many
occasions
we we get we became friends and then
there was father paschal
balmstein from belmont abbey down in
north carolina and he was there with
another monk because father pascal was
not well he had he had some
some brain problems that had required
surgery at one point
and he wasn't you know at that point uh
everything was kind of touch and go with
him so he had this this other monk
father john who had accompanied him to
just sort of help him out
and i talked with him a little bit at
the reception
and then later on i
talked with him and father john for a
good hour
at a breakfast at the hotel that we were
staying at
and i learned all sorts of things that i
didn't know about the benedictine rule
and about their way of life and about
how this
had influenced saint anselm and i didn't
realize this at the time
but i was talking with somebody who was
you know in the top tier of anselm
scholars
uh father pascal is a
was is still i mean he's he's uh
either in heaven or purgatory um
brilliant the anselm scholar who
who managed to to really dig into
certain aspects of anselm's thought that
other people
just had kind of passed over
and father paschall and i would continue
our conversations
and uh through correspondence
um and he became a very good
good friend of mine and a uh
he sort of pushed me to keep reading
this about ansel keep thinking about
this on anselm
um he was very encouraging
so i met them there and
didn't do anything with that paper they
they had a call for papers you know but
i didn't think it was good enough to
actually submit
then i went to the the second saint
anselm conference in 2002
and i gave a paper at that time i was
writing my dissertation on maurice
blondell and blown
had written a bit about anselm and the
ontological argument
and about descartes and marlboros
specifically so i wrote this this piece
which was later published in 2005 in the
saint anselm journal
and i i was in a panel basically about
about anselm and neoplatonism and that
that gave me a lot of
interesting things to think about as
well and then i started
really reading anselm seriously the the
second conference had
you know given me the idea there's a lot
more to this guy
than just this ontological argument i
better i better dig into this so i
started reading
you know the monologue and paying
attention to that and
seeing what wasn't contained in the
pro-slogan from the monologue and then i
started reading the the
three you know theological treatises
that are supposed to pertain to the
study of sacred scripture but are really
about moral life
and the will and its structure and truth
and
you know things like that uh the the on
truth on
freedom of choice and on the fall of the
devil and i was just being more and more
drawn in
in 2004 i started writing a paper
on something that had been under
explored in the pro-slogan you know
everyone
wants to focus on the one single
argument which actually runs the whole
the pro-slogan
and they think that it's pro-slogan two
through four the ontological argument
about god's existence
well there's other stuff in there and
there's this you know several chapters
about
how can god be merciful and just at the
same time which for me is a bigger
conundrum
than does god exist and anselm had a
really ingenious
way of of describing and discussing and
delving into this
that requires you know quite a bit of of
sort of mental gymnastics and i don't
mean that in the pejorative sense i mean
that in the
the laudatory sense you have to really
work your brain
in order to dig your way into these kind
of mysteries
and anselm provided an apparatus a
structure for for doing that in those
chapters
so i wrote a piece on mercy and justice
in saint anselm's pro-slogan
and i thought well where should i send
this so i sent it to american catholic
philosophical quarterly and they
accepted it
and then it was published later on in
2006.
i kept on reading and writing on anselm
and
in 2006 i gave a
conference paper at the indiana
philosophical association
and it was centered on the question you
know
what is actually saint anselm's argument
in the pro-slogan
and it kept getting bigger and bigger
and bigger
and eventually i've got to find
something to do with this this paper
because i've never published it
and it's it's grown perhaps too large to
actually even be a journal article
unless i send it to a european journal
or to you know philosophy and
phenomenological research one of these
journals that accepts longer
papers but it is uh quite quite
important because what i'm doing is
is taking the best scholarship on
you know and some a lot of it has been
overlooked here
in the anglo-american world a lot of the
french scholarship
especially reflexive philosophy talking
about ansem
and trying to make sense out of what is
actually going on here in this argument
in
anselm's own terms you have to think
about what anselm himself makes of
argument
what he thinks language is doing how
truth is is connected with ideas
so there was that and then i also
published another uh
piece in the saint anselm journal that
year in 2006
i was beginning to do the work that
would
eventually culminate in my book on the
christian philosophy debates
and i saw that anselm was a figure who
had been talked about
in the christian philosophy debates and
that their the implications that were
you know the positions that were being
taken had to do with whether
anselm's philosophy or thought was
actually christian philosophy or not so
i published
saint anselm's phoenix aquarius
intellectum as a
model for christian philosophy and
things started to really get
moving at that point 2007
i gave a paper entitled rather cheekily
when should students be beaten at the
midwest uh
medieval historical i think it's
association or conference or society
it was a new field for me you know
talking to historians about this
and it had the paper had to do with
anselm's
views on punishment and coercion and by
the way anselm's answer to when should
students be beaten very very rarely
as opposed to most the people of his his
own time
um and eventually i would i would have
that that
published in cistercian studies
quarterly they
accepted it entirely with the one
proviso that i had to change the title
because they didn't want
you know their their journal is the kind
that has like you know the titles of the
articles on it and they didn't want
people looking at it and saying
oh so the cistercians are about beating
beating students
so that got published as um
another another article um i gave uh
a conference paper at the american
catholic philosophical association
uh conference which was focused on
freedom and the will that your
excellent excellent conference um
i gave i gave a paper on anselm um
freedom inclinations of the will and and
moral virtue that was published in the
proceedings
um i got to meet kate rogers which it
was some
something that was really an important
thing for me um
kate rogers was still is a major
handsome scholar she's got a recent book
out on anne selman freedom
several other books um going back to her
years
all the way back to her doctoral work at
notre dame
um so meeting her was sort of like you
know
uh you know meeting your your favorite
rock star
and uh again very a lot of these anselm
scholars very down-to-earth people
we had some great conversations and
i've run into again at several other
conferences
2007 i also did something else i
i saw that the internet encyclopedia
philosophy article on anselm was very
short and they were looking for somebody
to write
a longer article so i said well i could
do that
so i did it and it was a long lengthy
writing process and then revision
process and and uh you know a lot of
work
but eventually it culminated in this
this encyclopedia article that um
is getting used by a lot of people to to
learn about who this this anselm guy is
and what his thought is
in 2008 um
one of the high points of my career uh
took place
and it it took place in part because of
of john fortin
um inviting me out to saint anselm
college
to give the annual saint anselm lecture
which to me felt like kind of a leap of
faith at the time you know
who who the hell am i and he asked me to
come out
and and give a you know the talk on
saint anselm
that year and so i did and i decided i
was going to take for my
my central theme um
god's simplicity and and our complexity
so i gave this talk it's about 45
minutes long
um you can see it if you want it's it's
published in the saint anselm journal
and there's a podcast of
of the talk and of my q a uh available
on on the saint anselm website
and i think i have links to it in my own
blog
website as well um
so it was called you know a
a simple god in our complicated moral
life so perfectly simple god in our
complicated moral lives
and it explored the nature of divine
simplicity the way that anselm
understands it and then how that
how that should should affect us us
human beings
i also um i moved down to car to
fayetteville that year and in the north
i
gave a paper in the north carolina
religious studies association
on anselm justice and ontological
dignity
anselm is a neoplatonist and and i you
know he distinguishes degrees of being
and i said that perhaps justice just
being should be understood
as adding a greater amplitude or dignity
uh ontological dignity of being to the
the human being controversial thesis
again a paper i haven't done much with i
did send it out to one journal
where it was rejected but in a very
weird way they said it was a great paper
but they couldn't publish it at the time
and then they just left it at that i i
sort of fell through the cracks
and i i didn't um send it out anywhere
else uh
2009 i i gave um a couple more
uh conference papers
uh one is fedex quierons uh
rectitudeness intellectum
christian faith and practical
rationality and anselm
i gave that at the fourth st anselm
conference in 2009
2009 was a very important year because
that was
um the anniversary of
a centennial uh 900 year anniversary of
anson's death
i gave another paper called the
personalist aspect of saint anselm's
neoplatonic metaphysics at the
the neo-platonism conference in
steubenville ohio at franciscan
university steubenville that was later
published
in their their journal questions dispute
disputate in 2011.
i had a paper that was supposed to be
published in a book that was going to
come out in 2009
called meeting god through moral life it
was about anselm's moral theory and
about how it would lead us to
understanding god
um how the practical and the theoretical
come together
and john fortin was was editing that and
that was kind of an interesting
uh turn of events because notre dame
press
ended up and this this is a volume that
had like
the who's who of anselm scholarship
contributing to it i was sort of
writing their coattails in as a junior
scholar
notre dame press passed on it after all
the essays had been written
and after things were supposed to like
go to uh
go to um the presses
and so all of these these papers just
were kind of orphaned
hung out to dry and i i haven't done
anything with mine that's becoming a
common theme
i'm realizing um another thing that was
really important for me
was that in 2009 in the summer
uh i i stayed for a portion of the
summer as a resident scholar
being supported by the institute for
saint anselm studies
and getting to do research uh in the
library the geisel library's saint
anselm collection
i also was able to participate in the
metaphysics colloquium which which is
held at saint anselm as well
and and that was a wonderful time uh the
back story of that was
i decided i wanted to write a book on
anselm and moral theory before i moved
down to fayetteville state university so
i was i was already beating to work on
it
and then at fayetteville state
university they
came up with these faculty development
grants and they said hey if you've got a
book
project you know something you're doing
we'll we'll help you out with it
we want to to help you you know develop
yourself as a scholar
just write yourself a grant proposal and
send it in and so i did and it was
you know it got accepted but it was a
huge huge hassle there were all sorts of
headaches
i'm not going to go into the whole story
but let's just say there was a ton of
mismanagement on fsu's part
shortly after the the money was starting
to finally get dispersed
we went into a budget crisis a massive
budget crisis and they started freezing
things
and i have never seen grant money
actually
taken back but that's what they did
they had agreed to and they had promised
that i would get money
for travel to these conferences and for
a stay
up at you know saint anselm's um
and i think i'd also written in there
some study at notre dame as well
they took back all of that so now i was
like
well i guess i'll just suck up the
conferences you know i'll have to pay
for those myself because i'm not going
to not go to the conferences but what am
i going to do about you know
this this summer of study that i had
planned to to work on my
on my book and
uh dwayne bruce stepped up he was by now
john fortin had uh had uh
moved on to to a lot of other things and
dwayne bruce
was now the the head of the institute
and
dwayne bruce um said well let me see
what i can do to help out
and there was a lot of sort of finagling
and making things work on a shoestring
and i i got myself up there i drove all
the way up to manchester and they put me
up in a dorm room
and um you know made the library
you know available to me hooked me up
the the research librarian
gave me a card for making copies um said
you know
whatever else you need let us know we
can't actually like you know give you
give you uh board money but here's
here's a room that you can actually stay
in
and you know you can get this work done
and so that was an
invaluable time for me it was it was a
great
outpouring of charity at a time in my
life when things were
were in many respects particularly dark
you know i was teaching at a school that
was
just going through all sorts of of uh
problems in a state that was
going through all sorts of problems my
my personal life was was kind of a mess
as well and i was trying to get my
scholarship back
back in gear after having had to jump
ship from you know the prison job that
i'd been teaching
down to fayetteville state university
only to find out that
things were in such a mess there so this
was kind of an oasis
for uh me to carry out some good
scholarship and i did
in 2010 i was contacted by
rhea press and asked if i wanted to
contribute to a volume
called living called uh death and
anti-death
volume seven nine hundred years after
saint anselm and i thought well that's
kind of weird stuff and it was tied in
with all this futurist
anti-death kind of kind of things but
they had some you know
some some you know pretty big name and
some scholars so i was like well
okay um seems you know like like a forum
where i could actually
write some some reasonable stuff on
saint anselm and get it in there and uh
so i said
i'm gonna do something on saint anselm
and eternal life and and
uh and human life temporal life
i said sure sounds good so i wrote
something called um
living towards eternal life saint
anselm's christian anthropology
i also gave a paper at the wisdom
conference
in wisconsin back in my home state
viterbo university up in la crosse
i gave a paper on human and divine
wisdom and anselm of canterbury
uh again which i haven't done anything
with i suppose i i really ought to
then uh 2012 once i'd moved up here to
new york i gave a paper
at the felician ethics conference um
what kind of moral theory does saint
anselm actually hold
another paper i still have to do
something with i've promised it to their
their journal actually but i haven't
revised it the way i ought to
and what was kind of interesting is is
that trip down there to felicia
which is in new jersey coincided with
going further down into new jersey
because my wife and i were invited by
saint anselm parish
to go as guests and give a dinner
address
and so i did a little talk about who is
saint anselm because
um you know they found out about me
through my internet article
uh you know the the internet
encyclopedia philosophy
entry on saint anselm which by the way
is
you know if you put it into like a paper
format it's like
um 50 pages long that's a that's a
pretty deep
long article
so anyway that was kind of fun i got to
meet a lot of nice people who were quite
interested in anselm
we were going to do some talks but then
of course um
uh you know the hurricane hit and kind
of put the kibosh on that and they've
been doing some rebuilding but
eventually
i think we'll probably do that and then
i recently gave a paper
well two papers um this year in 2013
one was in in april and it was at
another you know conference at
franciscan university steubenville uh
that was oriented around the question
must morality be grounded upon god and
so i gave a paper called an encelamian
grounding of morality
where i said yeah for anselm more or
less and here's how it would play itself
out
that paper i'm actually revising for um
for a very soon looming deadline for
cuiciones disputate
where they they want to publish uh the
conference
proceedings and papers the ones that
they particularly liked
and i recently gave another paper um
just this last
month in grand valley state university
because that's where the international
society for mcintyre
inquiry was it was called an overlooked
medieval occasion and some injustice
virtues and vices and moral inquiry it's
quite a mouthful there
and it was basically saying alistair
mcintyre is this great account of the
history of philosophy in the history of
moral theory
he talks about certain medievals but he
gives all this precedence to saint
thomas he talks about anselm a little
bit but
really only in terms of the ontological
argument here's how he could have talked
about saint anselm here's why saint
anselm was particularly important
for medieval thought and could still be
today
so um that's quite a
quite a a long discussion there about
how i ended up getting into
that and hopefully you got an idea that
you know it's not just about conference
papers or publications but
it's really about the content you know
some of the things that i write about
have to do with anselm's arguments and
what's going on with that
a lot of things on his moral theory
including the book that i'm working on
other things having to do with you know
time and eternity
or um other aspects of ansem's
thought friendship for example you know
the role that that played
um i got you know
the more and more that i research him
the more and more i'm finding
things that i'm i'm really uh drawn to
in his thought and so where my current
projects are a lot of those papers
actually got written because
i thought i was going to use them as as
chapters in the book that i'm
you know i'm writing i was going to say
supposed to be writing but i am writing
uh on sadie anselm's moral theory um
i've got several chapters actually
written although they'll probably get
revised as i
as i finish other chapters um i'm also
carrying out a project where i'm
translating the decimal to
nibus and later on after i get that done
i'll translate the the dicta and sell me
because i think these are works that
really deserve to be out there
and available to to non-latin readers um
and then where i'm going to go after
that i don't know i've i've submitted a
few other conference paper proposals
uh one recently for a paper on anselm
and
heidegger believe it or not having to do
with truth and nothingness
and i'll probably write on anselm the
rest of my life because there's so much
stuff there that i just haven't yet
explored
what i really need to do besides getting
my butt in gear
about the book is take a lot of these
papers that i've written
that haven't found a home yet and
find them a home either what i need to
do is get them into
journals uh which means actually going
through the business of sending them out
and then what you know if they get
rejected
send them somewhere else if they get
accepted it's usually you have to revise
something you know to fit their what
their bill
so i got to get on with that and either
that or i need to pitch them
as a book of essays because i actually
have enough unpublished ansem
essays that i could probably publish a
whole book
the problem with that is i'm i'm you
know when it comes to anselm studies
i would say that at this point in my
career i'm no longer a junior scholar
but i'm not in the you know like the top
tier of just big heavyweight and some
scholars that you know if you're going
to do something on hansel you better
bring these people in
i'm sort of in the middle ground people
in people who who are interested in
anselm know my work
um they may not know exactly what what
i'm what i'm doing
but um you know i get i get a lot of
good good compliments on on
doing good good scholarly and some
writing and and exploring interesting
avenues
in his thoughts sometimes i get from the
react the reaction from people
well there's two interesting reactions i
get from people one is the
i had no idea this was an anselm's work
because you know
people don't always read us widely and
the other is
i'm really not sure i understand what
you're talking about here
are you sure that anselm thinks that
and so i probably need to make a i
probably need to do a better job
in making a case for that sort of thing
so that's probably a good place to
close you know go from the perfectly
clear beginning to
ending in in mystery and ambiguity
i wanted to finish up this already
pretty long
video by showing you st anselm's college
and
in particular two places where i spent
quite a bit of time
during my summer stay there and two
places i like to go back to visit
so this is the the patron of saint
anselm college himself saint anselm
a very dramatic statue of him this is
one of the places this is the chapel
um interesting design to it
as you'll see in just a moment a
beautiful circular design
some some really interesting stained
glass for me this was a place where i
could
learn the how to pray the liturgy of the
hours by going there and doing so
with the monks which is something that i
i really
got a lot out of it was interesting
seeing how slow how meditative they were
with it and and it helped me to better
understand
how that ought to be how that ought to
be done
the other place where i spent a lot of
my time in study was
the saint anselm collection which is a
room in the geisel library on the second
floor
which is lined with these these uh
bookshelves
containing volumes dealing with saint
anselm either about saint anselm or
onsen anselm or
pursuing the scholarship further they
also have a lot of really interesting
old volumes that i try to keep my hands
off of because
i could probably you know just just
damage them and i don't have too much to
get out of them myself
but i do consult a lot of the studies
that are available
and i think younger scholars would find
that very handy as well
the other thing that's really remarkable
about this is that they gather all of
the research
as it comes out on saint anselm and they
categorize it and put it into these
boxes
and that is what i really worked from a
lot and i think that's what younger
scholars would find
most interesting there so that is my
life as a saint anselm scholar